there's so many new Beauty releases
happening all the time so we gathered
some of the most hyped products to test
for ourselves this is a face sprinkles
mini palette from designer dustco they
have a lot of different ones to choose
from and you can even make a custom
palette with any of their Glitters I was
trying to show all of the colors but I
couldn't lift it all the way because one
of the Glitters was completely liquefied
something weird happened to it on its
way to me but the rest of the Glitters
were totally fine the Glitter has a
vegan gel base that dries down you can
apply it on the face hair or body I was
having fun just putting it everywhere I
loved all the colors and it was really
easy to apply I'm not really into
Glitters but I think these worked great
and this is one of the more affordable
glitter gel palettes I've seen this is
the summer Friday's sheer skin tint it's
supposed to be lightweight hydrating and
very natural on the skin I definitely
think it is all of those things the
coverage is obviously sheer but I was
able to build it up no problem it evened
out my skin nicely and it actually does
feel weightless this would be a great
everyday skin tint for me I think for
what it is and how little product you
get forty two dollars is way too much
but if you're looking for a high-end
skin tint this one is really nice I had
been getting ads for this flower nose
strawberry Rococo collection for weeks
and they definitely worked on me because
I bought three products first up I tried
the embossed blush the detail in the
embossing is so cool I didn't even want
to use it they do say that this is meant
to be a buildable blush but I think the
color payoff is a little too light it
took me forever to get the color payoff
I wanted but it did look pretty in the
end onto the eyeshadow palette the matte
formula was soft and blendable but next
time I would go in with a primer first
because it was slightly patchy in some
areas the glitter shade was incredible
it was definitely the best shade in the
entire palette but it did give me some
Fallout lastly I tried the cloud lip
cream this is one of those moussey lip
formulas that has a velvety finish this
felt really nice and comfortable on the
lips and I like the Blurred effect it
gives but I kind of wish it was the same
red as the packaging this is the Cali
Ray so blown clean primer it's one of
the those dimethiconee blurring primers
that makes your skin look matte I
actually like how it made my skin look
without any foundation it feels nice and
velvety and I definitely saw some
blurring when I applied my Foundation I
realized I applied too much of the
primer so my skin actually looked kind
of textured and the product peeled up a
bit so the next time I tried it I went
in with less and focused on my oily
areas and I still wasn't loving how my
Foundation looked over this I just see
way more texture with this primer than
my normal primer I'll show them side by
side so maybe you can kind of see what I
mean I don't think that this is for me
Milani released this conceal and perfect
line with liquid under eye brighteners
Contours and highlighters these kind of
feel like a drugstore version of the
Charlotte Tilbury wands first I tried
the brightener under my concealer I
didn't notice much brightening at first
but then I applied it with my fingertips
and got some better coverage next I
tried the liquid Contour this color does
lean a little bit red which I don't love
but it Blended out really beautifully
and added a nice warmth to my face I
applied the highlighter next and I love
this again it Blends out really nicely
and it doesn't add any texture to my
skin it just gave a really pretty glow
even though I don't see myself using the
brightener I am a fan of these and I
hope they expand the shade range these
are the collidos Epiphany glow Melton
eyeliners they're all multi-chrome so
they have these really cool color shifts
Melton was the perfect description for
these because they really do glide on so
easily I've never had such a smooth
eyeliner application because they always
skip or they're too dry these are so
easy to apply I thought that the tip
would be too blunt to create a wing but
I was actually able to do it without any
issue these are really beautiful and I
highly recommend them I hope they expand
the line to include more everyday matte
Shades this is the got to be glued for
brows and edges for a long time people
have been using got to be hair gel as
brow gel so they came out with this
product that's actually meant for brows
I actually like how this made my brows
look it gives kind of a laminated brow
effect nice and feathery but the gel
itself left a weird residue behind and
it took forever to dry down once it did
dry the Brows pretty much stayed in
place but I've definitely tried better
brow gels
[Music]